new evidence of possible russian war
crimes the satellite images tell the
tale apparent mass graves just outside
the southern city of mariupol in
territory controlled by russia local
officials accuse russia of entombing
thousands of civilians in that area
you're looking at right now
thousands more ukrainians are trapped
inside a nearby steel works in marijuana
surrounded by forces loyal to vladimir
putin who is now claiming victory in
that city charlie dagetta is in dinipro
ukraine that's about 150 miles northwest
of mariupol charlie good morning
good morning to you tony the true
civilian death toll may not be known for
some time now some evacuations have been
taking place over the past couple of
days but not many people have been able
to escape and ukrainian officials
believe as many as a hundred thousand
civilians may still be trapped inside
the city
smoke billows above the twisted ruins of
the steel plant where at least a
thousand fighters and civilians remain
trapped in an underground maze
surrounded by russian forces
above ground they're collecting the
bodies everywhere
new satellite images appear to show long
lines of graves about 200 near the port
city where local officials accuse the
russian military of burying civilians in
an effort to hide the horrors that have
taken place
civilian casualties are mounting along
the front line of fighting
in heart cave paramedics scrambled to
save their own lives while tending to a
wounded woman this week
harkev has suffered from intense
bombardment since this conflict began
and even while we've been here
explosions have been ringing out
throughout the day the mayor said the
russians are furiously bombing the city
yana bacha came to visit her father only
to find out he was killed by a chunk of
shrapnel when he stepped out of his
apartment to buy bread
even in war
he
tried to smile to joke to support us
he said that you are my brave girls you
are heroes that daily risk has left
those seeking shelter living in this
subway tunnel for two months on the
platform pavel ferrashenko hands out
pizzas to excited children and their
parents the tab is picked up by complete
strangers people who fled the city
calling up and ordering pizza for those
left behind
he says he now has foreigners treating
paramedics and soldiers to pizza daddy's
pizza has now got a paypal account to
keep up
you made a lot of children
and a lot of people very happy
for a few moments
how does that make you feel
joyful he said bringing a little slice
of happiness here seeing kids laugh
taste of the normal life
it feels fantastic
now we're headed into the orthodox
easter weekend here there had been some
hope of an easter truce but president
zielinski said the russians rejected
that proposal
jamie
that's too bad charlie dagida in ukraine
thank you